[Música]
en Venezuela la oposición se alista para
unas elecciones primarias en las que
escogerán quién será la persona que
enfrentará al presidente Nicolás Maduro
en los comicios presidenciales de 2024 a
un año de la esperada votación todavía
no existe una figura definida dentro de
los contrarios al oficialismo y esto se
da a raíz de una combinación de factores
políticos estratégicos e ideológicos
Cuáles son para análisis saludamos en
Caracas a colette capriles ella es
profesora en el departamento de ciencias
sociales de la universidad Simón Bolívar
y además es miembro electa de la
academia de ciencias políticas y
sociales de Venezuela señora capriles
bienvenida directo a América
Muchísimas gracias empezamos con una
pregunta que tal vez engloba toda esta
todo este todo este tema y es Cuáles son
las principales razones por las cuales
la posición venezolana el día de hoy no
ha logrado alcanzar un consenso
unificado en sus objetivos políticos
bueno
eso nos llevaría casi una disertación no
porque son muchos años en en en este
conflicto
tan complicado que lleva Venezuela no
yo me voy a referir a la coyuntura me
voy a referir a la situación en la que
estamos en este momento
esencialmente hay una tesis fundamental
que yo creo que nadie puede objetar Y es
que es muy necesario para poder
transformar el conflicto político en
Venezuela y poder aspirar a la
alternabilidad política es necesario
cumplir al menos dos condiciones
una es efectivamente una oposición unida
estratégicamente
eso pues como digo es bastante
complicado comentarlo pero creo que se
entiende que debe haber una oposición
que no sea que no esté en la condición
en la que está ahora que es precisamente
pues muy fragmentada y enfrentada entre
Sí además con conflictos internos
precisamente porque no hay una
estrategia común no básicamente ha
habido dos estrategias una estrategia
digamos de crecimiento
progresivo de las fuerzas de la
oposición y de participación electoral y
hubo y quizás todavía la hay otra
estrategia en la cual la teoría del
cambio en una teoría en la cual había
que construir las condiciones inmediatas
para una alternancia
ejerciendo la mayor presión posible
sobre el gobierno chavista esas dos
teorías deberían esa contradicción esas
dos teorías estratégicas ha ocasionado
fragmentación dentro de la oposición
y en esa fragmentación todavía estamos
la Otra condición es que tiene que haber
precisamente por esas condiciones de
fragmentación tiene que haber un acuerdo
político un acuerdo institucional y un
acuerdo de nación para poder llevar
adelante unas elecciones que sirvan que
realmente sirvan para transformar el
conflicto político No simplemente para
cambiar un gobierno sino para
reconstruir las bases institucionales de
la gobernanza y incluso de la del
funcionamiento del estado y ese es el
proceso que se ha intentado desde 2019
que tuvo algún fruto el año pasado con
el acuerdo social en noviembre Pero que
está paralizado en este momento Entonces
en este momento estamos en una situación
de incertidumbre
el proceso mediante el cual la oposición
Quisiera poder alcanzar un candidato
único es un proceso complicado a través
de primaria que todavía no es tan Clara
en el que no necesariamente va a
participar toda la oposición por una
parte y por otra parte el las
conversaciones estaban las
conversaciones y la negociación está
paralizada esa es la situación ahora
hablemos de los personajes que están en
el centro de la discusión por ejemplo
Juan guaidó si bien este líder opositor
logró en su momento fue ser visto de
alguna forma desde fuera desde Venezuela
como esa figura unificadora de la
posición dentro del país la situación
era muy distinta Cuál es la percepción
que se tiene hoy sobre Juan guaidó
Bueno la verdad es que la figura de Juan
guaidó es una figura controversial y
complicada porque efectivamente llegó un
momento
en el que Juan guaidó parecía ser el
líder o unificador pero durante la
gestión del llamado gobierno interino y
cuando empieza a ver contradicciones
dentro del mismo grupo de la oposición
dentro de la misma oposición en torno a
Cómo manejar Esa esa gobernanza y y Cómo
resolver la situación
extraña que se había creado con dos
gobiernos
y también hay que decirlo así por el
fracaso mismo de la estrategia de máxima
presión que Juan guaidó encarnaba
digamos el el gobierno interino es una
expresión de esa
estrategia de crear una situación de
facto digamos en la que la ilegitimidad
de maduro operar como palanca para
precipitar un cambio político y eso no
ocurrió entonces
la capacidad de liderazgo de Juan guaidó
fue disminuyendo y yo creo que hoy pues
es una figura
bastante colateral que no deja de tener
cierta influencia en ciertos sectores
sobre todo en Estados Unidos pero que
fundamentalmente no no tiene liderazgo
propio no en este momento bien otro de
los nombres que suenan es Enrique
capriles por ejemplo que por tercera vez
Busca llegar a la presidencia pero está
inhabilitado para ejercer cargos
públicos De qué manera esto se ve como
un obstáculo para que la oposición pueda
encontrar esa figura de la que estamos
hablando
bueno el tema de las inhabilitaciones de
nuevo es un asunto político esto no
nunca ha sido un asunto judicial ni
jurídico sino que es un asunto político
y Es evidente que son instrumentos que
el gobierno de maduro utiliza
arbitrariamente para
modular las decisiones de la oposición
Es evidente que esa esa inhabilitaciones
la de Enrique capriles y cualquier otra
tienen un valor de cambio político y en
la medida en que pudieran negociarse
condiciones generales para tanto la la
presidenciales como las elecciones
generales del año veinticinco esas
inhabilitaciones podrían estar en la
mesa como una forma
digamos para hacer negociadas y para
hacer para que haya un compromiso de no
repetirlas y de no mantenerlas y no
repetirlas pero de nuevo es el asunto de
no tener el espacio para la negociación
No mira capriles profesora en el
departamento de ciencias sociales de la
universidad Simón Bolívar Gracias por
acompañarnos gracias por brindarnos este
tiempo aquí en directo América gracias a
ustedes bien De esta manera despedimos
otro bloque de directo a América en
France 24 pero ya regresamos con más
quédense con nosotros
[Música]